[MUSIC PLAYING]
HOST: I'll be very brief.
I promise.
On behalf of the Council
for the arts at MIT,
I'd like to welcome all
of you here this evening.
As Maureen said, the 1998
Eugene McDermott award
was presented to Junot
Diaz last November.
And we're very fortunate to
have him here with us this week
for a short residency at MIT.
Junot Diaz was born in
the Dominican Republic
and moved to the United
States at the age of seven.
Much of his fiction
draws on this experience,
as he writes about the clash
and confluence of cultures,
and that sense of
dislocation, which
is so much a part of the
immigrant experience.
His stories take
us back and forth
between the streets
of Santa Domingo
and the neighborhoods of New
Jersey where he and his family
settled.
Junot Diaz writes with a
jeweler's eye for detail
and an unsparing, honest voice.
He confronts issues of racism
and ethnic identity, sexuality,
and family turmoil,
while taking issue
with the empty promises
of the American dream.
His first book of fiction titled
Drown received unanimous praise
from critics when it
was published in 1996.
He currently teaches creative
writing at Syracuse University
and has had his stories
selected for the best American
short stories, both
in 1996 and in 1999.
Just a week ago, he was awarded
a Guggenheim fellowship.
So he has lots to celebrate.
Please join me in
welcoming Junot Diaz.
[APPLAUSE]
DIAZ: Thanks a lot.
HOST: Do you want
to take a seat?
DIAZ: It's OK.
Yo, wild and out up front.
They immediately start laughing
as soon as I walk over.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DIAZ: Oh, did I throw it.
Actually, I want to thank y'all.
Did I throw it?
Was I bad?
[? Thank. ?]
No, I feel like I sometimes
fuck up in public.
So I actually wanted
to thank the council.
I wanted to thank MIT, of
course, for hosting me.
And thank you all
for coming out on--
and I look around.
I know you guys work hard.
So this means a lot for you all
to come out for a little bit.
So I wanted to
thank you for that.
And also, I wanted to thank
the Eugene McDermott people
for giving me the
prize that got me out
of Syracuse for a couple days.
As you know, we're getting
pounded by snow so.
So I'm kind of enjoying
this little break.
And I also wanted
to thank Maureen.
She drove me around all day.
I know I've been busting
her fucking hump.
So she's been
wonderful, you know?
Because I'm really bad and mean.
So she's put a really
good face on it.
And Steve [? Alter ?] who
came and got me today,
he's been great too.
He's been a real gentleman.
And I actually want to say final
words for my dear friend Anita
Desai, who I don't think y'all--
I'm sure y'all don't appreciate
her as much as one should.
She's fucking brilliant, man.
I love her.
I really I wish that
we had enough loot
where I went to school
so we could kidnap her.
You guys wouldn't
stand a chance.
So she's been wonderful.
And I love the gossip
with Anita too.
We like the same writers, so
we get to gossip all the time.
And I'm not going to read long.
I think it's always
better to keep it short.
So I'm just going to
read two small stories,
and then I'm going
to just open up
for just a couple of questions.
There was a student I
met earlier in a class
from the Bronx.
Is he here?
Yeah.
Well, you know what?
After I left you, I remembered
my [? man ?] street.
It's called Manor.
I'm sure you know Manor, right?
Do you?
Well Manor, I fucked
up, because I was
saying it was called Mansion.
And then I walked out.
I'm like, oh, you shouldn't
give somebody from the Bronx
the wrong street name.
I figured you went home and
went, like, oh, that punk.
So I just thought
I'd clear that up.
And the first story I'm going
to read is just from the book.
And then I'm going to
read a new story, which
is sort of strange
because it's kind
of fragmented and
impressionistic,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And this is just
a real short one.
And this story came about--
it actually came about
from living in Brooklyn.
I lived in Brooklyn for--
like I first left New Jersey,
I came and lived in
Brooklyn for a few years.
And Brooklyn's a weird
place because just the rate
it's being gentrified.
So I remember when I
moved into my street,
it was like mad cool.
It was just a nice
street to live in.
It looked like any place else.
But then about a year later,
every time somebody moved out
of their apartment, they would
build a wall down the apartment
and make it to two apartments.
And then our street went
from a normal street
with young people.
And then I remember
one day we walked out
and we saw kids outside
skateboarding, which
is the first sign in
New York that you're
being gentrified when you
see white kids skateboarding.
You know you're
shit out of luck.
So we had to move out
in like six months.
They raised the rent six times.
So it came out of that
experience living in Brooklyn
and from living in these
apartments with really
thin walls.
I had a neighbor.
I had this neighbor,
these Dominican kids.
And it was strange because we
knew more about the boyfriend
than the girlfriend did.
So they would be
like all lovey dovey.
We'd see them in the hallway.
They'd be smooching and
[SPANISH],, and stuff like that.
And then she would
go away on a break.
And the next day my man
would have some girl
up at his apartment.
And we'd be like, oh, shit.
And then two days later
homegirl would come home
and he'd be like, I missed you.
And we could hear it
through the walls.
So in honor of my man, I wrote
this story called Boyfriend.
And here it goes.
I should have been careful.
I should have been
careful with the weed.
Most people it just fucks up.
Me, it makes me sleepwalk.
And wouldn't you know, I woke up
in the hallway of our building
feeling like I'd been stepped
on by my high school marching
band.
My ass would have
been there all night
if the folks in
the apartment below
hadn't been having themselves
a big old fight at 3:00
in the morning.
I was too fried to move,
at least right away.
Boyfriend was trying
to snake girlfriend
saying he needed his space.
And she was like,
mother fucker, I'll
give you all the space you need.
I knew boyfriend a little.
I saw him at the bars,
and saw some of the girls
he used to bring home
while she was away.
He just needed more
space to cheat.
You can just come on in, guys.
Don't even fuck with it.
He just needed more
space to cheat.
Fine, he said.
But every time he went for
the door, she got to crying
and would be like, why
are you doing this to me?
They sounded a lot like me
and my old girlfriend Loretta.
But I swore to
myself that I would
stop thinking about her ass even
though every Cleopatra looking
Latina in the city made
me stop and wish she
would come back to me.
By the time boyfriend got
himself into the hallway,
I was already in my apartment.
And girlfriend, girlfriend
would not stop crying.
Twice she tried.
She must have heard me moving
around right above her.
And both times I held my breath
until she started up again.
I followed her
into the bathroom,
the two of us separated by a
floor, wires, and some pipes.
And she kept saying
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
and washed her face
over and over again.
It would've broken
my heart if it
hadn't been so damn familiar.
I guess I'd gotten used
to that sort of thing.
I had a heart leather
like walruses got blubber.
The next day I told my
boy Harold what happened.
And he said, too bad for her.
And I said, I guess so.
And he said, if I didn't
have my own women problems,
I'd say let's go
comfort the widow.
And I said, she ain't our type.
And he said, the hell she ain't.
Homegirl, homegirl was
too beautiful and too high
class for a couple of
knuckleheads like us.
We never saw her in a
t-shirt or without jewelry.
And her boyfriend
[INAUDIBLE],, that nigga
could have been a model.
Hell, they both could
have been models,
which is what they probably
were considering that I never
heard word one passed between
them about a job or a fucking
boss.
People like these were
untouchables to me,
raised on some other planet
and then transplanted
into my general vicinity to
remind me how bad I was living.
What was worse was how
much Spanish they shared.
None of my
girlfriends ever spoke
Spanish, even Loretta of
the Puerto Rican attitudes.
The closest thing for
me was this black chick
who spent three years in Italy.
She liked to talk
that shit in bed
and said she'd gone with
me because I reminded her
of some of the Sicilian
men she'd known,
which was why I never
called her again.
Boyfriend-- boyfriend came
around a couple more times
that week for his things and
I guess to finish the job.
He was a confident prick.
He listened to what
she had to say,
arguments that had taken
her hours to put together.
And then she would sigh
and say it didn't matter.
He needed his space
[SPEAKING SPANISH]..
She let him fuck her
every time, maybe hoping
that it would make him stay.
But, you know, once somebody
gets a little escape velocity
going, there ain't
no play in the world
that will keep them from going.
I would listen to them going at
it, and I would be like, damn.
Ain't nothing more shabby
than those farewell fucks.
I know.
Me and Loretta had enough
of those to go around.
The difference was we never
talked the way these two would
about our days, not even
when we were cool together.
We'd lay there and listen
to the world outside,
to the loud boys, the
cars, the pigeons.
And back then, I didn't have
a clue what she was thinking.
But now I know what to pencil
into all those empty thought
bubbles, escape, escape.
These two though, these two
had a thing about the bathroom.
Each one of his visits ended
up there, which was fine by me.
It was where I could
hear them the best.
I don't know why I started
following her life,
but it seemed like
a good thing to do.
Most of the time, I thought
people, even at their worst,
were pretty fucking boring.
The bathroom, girlfriend talked
a mile a minute about her day,
how she saw a fistfight
on the C train
and how somebody
liked her necklace.
And boyfriend, with his
smooth Barry White voice,
just kept going,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
They'd shower together.
And if she wasn't talking,
she was going down on him.
All you would hear
down there was
the water smacking
the bottom of the tub
and him going, yeah, yeah.
He wasn't sticking
around though.
That was obvious.
He was one of those dark
skin smooth-faced brothers
that women kill for.
And I knew for a fact having
seen his ass in action
at the local spots
that he'd like
to get over on the white girls.
She did know nothing about
his little Rico Suave routine.
It would have wrecked her.
I used to think those were
the barrio rules, Latinos
and blacks in, whites out,
a place we down cats weren't
supposed to go.
But love teaches you.
It breaks your-- but
love teaches you.
It clears your
head of any rules.
Loretta's new
boyfriend was Italian
and worked on Wall Street.
When she told me about him,
we were still going out.
We were on the promenade, and
she said to me, I like him.
He's a hard worker.
And no amount of heart leather
could stop something like that
from hurting.
After one of their showers,
boyfriend never came back,
no phone calls, no nothing.
She called a lot of her
friends, ones she hadn't
spoken to in the longest.
I survived through my boys.
I didn't have to
call out for help.
It was easy for them to
say forget her sellout ass.
That's not the sort
of woman you need.
Look how light you are.
No doubt she was already
shopping for the lightest.
Mostly, girlfriend spent her
time crying, either in bathroom
or in front of the TV.
And I spent my time listening
and calling around for a job,
or smoking, or drinking
a bottle of rum
and two sixes of
Presidente a week.
And one night, one night I
got the [SPEAKING SPANISH]
to ask her out for cafe, which
was mighty manipulative of me.
She hadn't had much human
contact the whole month
except with the delivery guy
from the Japanese restaurant,
a Colombian dude I
always said hi to.
So what the hell was
she going to say to me?
No?
She seemed glad to hear my name.
And when she threw
open the door,
I was surprised to see her
looking smart and watchful.
She said she'd be right up.
And when she sat down across
from me at the kitchen table,
she had on a makeup and
a rose gold necklace.
You have a lot more
light in your apartment
than I do, she said, which
was a nice call about all I
had in the apartment was light.
I played
[SPEAKING SPANISH] for her.
And then we drank a pot of cafe.
El pico, I told her,
nothing but the best.
We didn't have
much to talk about.
She was depressed and tired.
And I had the worst
gas of my life.
Twice, I had to excuse
myself, twice in an hour.
She must have thought
that bizarre as hell.
But both times I came
out of the bathroom
she was staring
deeply into her coffee
the way the fortune tellers
will do back on the island.
Crying all the time had
made her more beautiful.
Grief will do that
sometimes, not for me.
Loretta had been
gone now for months,
and I still look like shit.
Having girlfriend in
the apartment only
made me feel shabbier.
She picked up a cheeb seed
from a crack in the table
and she smiled.
Do you smoke, I ask?
It makes me break out, I said.
It makes me sleepwalk.
Honey will stop that, she said.
It's an old Caribbean cure.
I had a deal who
would sleepwalk,
and one teaspoon a night
took it out of him.
I never tried the honey,
and she never came back.
Whenever I saw her on the
stairs, we would trade hi's.
But she's never
slowed down to talk,
never gave a smile, or any
other kind of encouragement.
I took that as a hint.
At the end of the
month, she got her hair
cut short, no more
straighteners, no more
science fiction combs.
I liked that, I told her.
I was coming back
from the liquor store
and she was on her way
out with a woman friend.
I like that.
It makes you look fierce.
She smiled.
That's exactly what I wanted.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I keep waiting for that
boyfriend to write me a letter,
you know, on the real though.
I always think
this takes longer.
Then I look at my watch and
realized oh, I must go on.
So I used to go--
for all you prospective
young writers,
I used to go see other writers.
You know, you would
go to their readings.
And the majority of them
were absolutely unbearable
because so many of them
would read for 59 minutes.
And you could feel
your beard growing.
So I had this thing.
I always promised myself to
keep it as short as possible.
This is a story.
This is something.
I was sort of working on
this cycle of stories.
Come on in.
I was working on this
cycle of stories.
And it was kind of strange
because, once again, I
was sort of dealing with people
dating and their relationship.
And I was moving through this
life of a fictional Dominican
cat.
And it was sort of
strange because I
was moving through
all the relationships
this guy had in his entire
life, from the time when
he was in second grade,
and some girl was like,
me and my girlfriend
want to date you,
from the time where
he's sort of telling
his story from his
mother's basement,
and all his Romeo
days are burnt out,
and he's now living
with his mother,
you know, like so many men I
know living with their moms.
So he's sort of down
in the basement,
like writing his little thing.
And so this comes
out of that section.
And it's this-- and it was
weird because in the book,
it's like--
I don't know.
I'm always just twisting the
knife in brothers in a way
because I'm one of them.
And it's good to be--
so we're talking about the--
I grew up with Cubans.
And I love that term.
I love that, almost
that cultural pattern,
[SPEAKING SPANISH],,
which so many of them
bring from the island
self-criticism.
I adore that shit.
So I was writing this thing
about when we were young,
my friends were young,
and they were all--
my friends, we were all
wild and out on white girls.
There was this obsession.
And all the cats
thought they were better
looking than sisters, you know?
And so much of it was like
weird ass self-hatred.
Well, maybe some of you don't
know what I'm talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
But fuck it.
So I took this segment out of
that kind of perverse stuff.
And that's where it comes from.
And it's a short called Flaca.
And you'll have to bear with
me because not only is only
it something new, but I'm
also working with a style
where lately I've been like
fragmenting shit, which
means that it makes a lot sense
less sense than it should.
Good luck.
[? Flaca, ?] your
left eye used to drift
when you were tired or upset.
It's looking for a way
out, you used to say.
And those days we
saw each other,
it fluttered, and
rolled, and you
had to put your finger
over it to stop it.
You were doing this when
I woke up and found you
on the edge of my chair.
You were still in your
teacher's uniform,
but your jacket was off.
And enough buttons were
open on your blouse
to show me the black bra
that I had bought you
and the freckles on your chest.
We didn't know it was the
last days, but we should have.
I just got here, you said.
And I looked out where
you'd parked your Saturn.
Go roll up them windows, I said.
I'm not going to be
here long, you said.
Someone's going to steal it.
I'm almost ready to go.
You stayed in your
chair, and I knew
better than to move closer.
You had an elaborate
system that you thought
would keep us out of bed.
You sat on the other
side of the room,
you didn't let me
crack your knuckles,
and you never stayed
more than 15 minutes.
It never worked.
I brought you guys
some dinner, you said.
I was making lasagna
for my class,
so I brought the leftovers.
My
Room back then
was small and hot.
And you never wanted
to be in there.
It's like being inside
of a sock, you said.
And any time the boys were away,
we slept in their living room
out on the rug.
Your long hair was
making you sweat,
and finally, you took your
hand away from your eye.
You hadn't stopped talking.
Today, I was given
a new student.
Her mother told me to
be careful with her
because she had the sight.
And I said, the sight?
And she said, you said the site.
I asked the senora if the
site helped her in school.
And she said, no, not really.
But it's helped me with
the numbers a few times.
I knew I was supposed to laugh.
But I stared outside instead
where a mitten-shaped leaf
had stuck to your windshield.
You stood besides me.
When I first saw you in our
Joyce class and then at gym,
I knew I'd call you Flaca.
And if you'd been
Dominican, my neighbors
would have worried about
you and brought you
plates of food to my door, heaps
of platano and yucca smothered
in quesco frito.
Flaca, even though
your name was Veronica,
the boys will be
here soon, I said.
Maybe you should
roll up your windows.
I'm going now, you said,
and you put your hand back
over your eye.
Too, I remember the boys
keeping an eye on me
because they were convinced
that I was going to flip out.
They figured two years ain't
no small thing, even though
that entire time I
never claimed you.
But what was nuts
was that I felt fine.
I felt like summer had
opened up shop inside of me.
And I told the boys
this was the best
decision that I'd ever made.
You can't be fucking with
white girls all your life.
And they looked at me like
I had a hole in my head.
After you dropped
me off that night,
the old man and
stinky wanted to know
what the fuck I was thinking.
And I said, I'm thinking
we should go out tonight.
I'm thinking I got to
find me a sister soon.
Three, I remember
we met in class.
You never spoke, but
I did all the time.
And once you looked at
me and I looked at you.
And you turned so red,
even the professor noticed.
You were white trash from
outside of Patterson,
and it showed in your
no fashion sense.
And you dated niggers a lot.
I said, you had
a thing about us.
And you said, angry, no.
I do not.
And I remember you used to offer
me rides home in your Saturn.
And I remember the
third time I accepted.
And our hands touched in the
front seat, little fugitives.
Four, it wasn't supposed
to get serious between us.
I can't see us getting
married or nothing.
And you nodded your head
and said you understood.
Then we fucked so that we
could pretend that nothing
hurtful had just happened.
This was like our
fifth time together.
And you got dressed
in a black sheath
and a pair of Mexican sandals.
And you said I could
call you when I wanted
but that you wouldn't call me.
You have to decide where
and when, you said.
If you leave it up to me, I
want to see you every day.
At least you were honest,
which is more than I can say
for a lot of people, who
pretend to be mad independent
and aren't.
Weekdays, I never called you--
didn't even miss you.
I had my boys and my
job to keep me busy.
But Friday and Saturday nights
when I didn't meet anybody
at the clubs, I called.
Those days, none of us
wanted to go to bed alone.
And I wasn't no different.
We talked until the silences
were long, until finally, you
asked, do you want to see me?
You made me say yes.
I want to see you.
And while I waited for you, I
would tell the boys it's just
sex, you know, nothing more.
And you would come with a
change of clothes and a pan
so you could make us
breakfast, maybe cookies
you have baked for your class.
And the boys would
find you in the morning
in one of my shirts.
And at first they
didn't complain
because they figured
you would just
go away like the
other white girls who
would pass through the house.
By the time they started
saying something,
it was late, wasn't it?
Five , you wanted
to go somewhere,
so I took us out to Spruce Run.
We'd both been
there as children.
You could remember the
years, even the months.
But the closest I came to
was back when I was young.
Look at the Queen
Anne's lace, you said.
You were leaning out the
window in the night air,
and I had my hand on
your back just in case.
What did your family
do here, you asked?
I looked at the night water.
We had barbecues,
Dominican barbecues.
My father didn't know
how to, but he insisted.
He would cook up this
red sauce that he'd
splatter on [SPEAKING SPANISH],,
and then he'd
invite complete strangers
over to eat with us.
It was horrible.
I wore an eye patch when
I was a kid, you said.
Maybe we met out here and fell
in love over bad barbecue.
And I said, I doubt it.
And you said, I'm just
saying, [INAUDIBLE]..
Maybe 5,000 years
ago we were together.
And you said, 5,000 years
ago I was in Denmark.
And I said that's true.
And about half of
me was in Africa.
And you said, doing what?
And I said, farming, I
guess, because that's
what everybody does everywhere.
Maybe we were together
some other time.
And I said, I can't think when.
You tried not to look at me.
Maybe 5 million years ago.
And I said, people weren't
even people back then.
That night, you lay in bed awake
and listen to the ambulance
tear down our street.
You were hot from something.
Your cheek could've kept
my room warm for a week.
And I didn't know how you
stood the heat of yourself,
of your breast, of your face.
I almost couldn't touch you.
And out of nowhere
you said, I love you,
for whatever that's worth.
Six, some nights I can't
sleep, and some nights I
pull on my sneakers and run.
These are the only times
I break two miles, when
there's no traffic and the
halogens turn everything
the color of foil and fire
up every bit of moisture
that's on the cars.
I run down and around
the memorial homes
along George Street, past
troop where the Camelot stands
boarded and burned,
I stay up entire nights.
And when the old man
comes home from UPS,
I'm noting down the
times the trains arrive
from Princeton junction.
You can hear them breaking from
our living room, a [? nash ?]
just south of my heart.
And I think this staying
up means something.
But the old man
hears me and laughs.
He's a brother who believes
in the practical and hardwood
floors and paperclips.
You need another job, he says.
And he shows me his beaten
up hands, a good one.
That's what this is about.
You need something that
will give you dreams.
You can't sleep without dreams.
Right now, you're just all out.
Six, last section.
Hmm.
We went back to
Spruce Run once more.
Do you remember, when the
fights seemed to go on and on,
and every one ended with us
in bed tearing at each other,
like maybe that could
change anything?
In a couple of months, you'd
be seeing someone else.
And I would too.
She was no darker than you,
but she watched her panties
in the shower and had
hair like a sea of little
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
And the first time you saw us
, you turned around and boarded
a bus I knew you
didn't have to take.
That second trip I stood on the
beach and watched you wade out,
watched you rub the lake on
your skinny arms and neck.
Both of us were hungover, and
I didn't want any of me wet.
There's a cure in the
water, as you said.
The priest announced
it at service.
You were saving some in a bottle
for your cousin with leukemia
and your aunt with
the bad heart.
You had on a bikini
bottom and a t-shirt.
And there was a mist
sifting down over the water
lacing the trees.
You went out to your
waist and stopped.
I was staring at you, and
you were staring up at me.
And right then it was something
sort of like love, wasn't it?
That night, you came into my
bed, too thin to be believed.
And when I tried
to kiss you, you
put your hand across my chest.
Wait, you said.
Downstairs the boys were
watching TV and screaming.
You let the water dribble out
of your mouth, and it was cold.
You reached my knee before you
had the refill from the bottle.
I listened to your
breathing, how slight
it was, and listen to the sound
the water made in the bottle.
You whispered my
full name, and I
remember how the next morning
you were gone, completely gone.
And nothing in my
bed or in my house
could have proven otherwise.
And that's that for that one.
[APPLAUSE]
Have I done enough?
AUDIENCE: You've done it.
DIAZ: OK, it's weird because the
second story is more internal.
And lately, I've been writing
these more internal things
that end up being kind
of dull to listen to.
So you've got to
deal with it though.
Do you have any questions?
Oh, couldn't wait.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, couldn't wait.
Where did you do
your formal training,
and what steps did you take
to get your first election
of stories [INAUDIBLE]?
DIAZ: Formal training,
could you elaborate exactly?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do an MFA, or--
DIAZ: OK, thank you.
Yeah.
No, thank you for your question.
I had started writing when
I was a junior or senior
in undergraduate.
And I was accepted into an MFA.
I applied to five
of them because I
couldn't afford more than five.
And I got denied
everywhere but Cornell,
which was funny, because
Cornell was quote,
unquote "good
school" I applied to.
So it shows you how fucking
arbitrary this shit is.
I didn't kid myself.
I got in.
I used to be like,
I didn't accept--
I didn't get accepted to
Vermont Mount College, you know?
And I went there for my MFA.
But mostly, I was telling
some other students before,
I really wilded out in
my MFA, because mostly I
was a community organizer.
And so when I got
there, I came in.
It was back when Cornell
grad school was still letting
in kids from state schools.
And so they accidentally
let a bunch of us
in from New Jersey who
all knew each other.
And none of us went to class.
And we just wilded out for the
Latino and black community.
And so it was only
till my senior year
that I really started
to take it seriously.
AUDIENCE: And how did you
get your own first collection
of stories published?
DIAZ: Yeah.
I mean, we say it at
home [SPEAKING SPANISH]..
It was just a complete accident.
I published one story.
I had been in graduate school.
After three years, I hadn't
sent in a story anywhere.
And I had gone to see my chair.
And she was like--
because if you do
a lot of activism,
which we'll talk
about in a minute,
you're more than
likely to be despised
by everyone in your department.
And so I had done all this
activism, and one of it
was critiquing the
English department.
And so we like really rammed
it to the English department
because a lot of us were
sitting on these committees,
and so we went berserk on them.
And what happened
was we forced them
to hire two faculty in
the English department
on doing US Latino studies.
We just screwed them.
We got Helena Maria
Viramontes in there,
and we got somebody
in the PhD program.
And so it was really
a big success for us.
And then I went to my chair
to get her to sign off on me,
and she was like,
I'm not signing it.
Fuck you.
And then I knew I had to leave
because if they don't sign off,
you might as well go home.
So I was on my--
I said, fuck, I'm doomed.
And I hadn't sent
in any stories out,
and so I sent my
first story out.
And it was like--
talk about ancestrals
looking out
because the first
story I sent out
was accepted and published
by Story Magazine,
and I was telling the
other students before.
They were like-- and Story was
like, do you have another one?
And I sent them another one,
and they were like, oh, OK,
we like this one, too.
And then I was
telling the students,
another class of students.
I was like, OK, so I've made
all of $500 on two stories.
I got to go home now, and
what ended up happening was
I had gone home.
I was making photocopies,
and a few months into that,
and an agent called.
And she was like, oh,
I like your stories.
I'd like to represent you.
And I was like, OK.
She's like, you don't
want to meet me?
I'm like, not really.
I'm desperate.
So and then a few months later
after that, she was like--
oh, by the way, she
called me at work.
They used to think--
I was working at
Pfizer Pharmaceuticals.
They used to think I
didn't speak English.
I was so sullen.
I wouldn't speak to anybody.
They would just give
me photocopies to make.
So I was making photocopies,
and homegirl called me.
She was like, oh, I
just sold your book.
Quit.
And so that was that.
It sounds like a
fancy, funny story,
but what's funny about
that story is that I
don't fucking kid myself.
It's like the lottery
because every one of us
who make it like this, that
actually means a thousand
other young writers of
color didn't make it
because it's like a selection
process which definitely
doesn't favor us.
So my friends-- we were all
like, yeah, this is great.
It's nice to eat,
but at the same time,
we knew every one of us would
get one of these positions
locks out another 20 people.
And that's not something
to be all cheery about.
Next question.
Right here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] race
and beauty in the Dominican
Republic [INAUDIBLE]
What affect did
that have [INAUDIBLE]
race [INAUDIBLE] beauty,
and how do you work
it out in writing?
DIAZ: Do we have any
other Dominicans here?
Raise your hand.
All right.
Could you answer
that question for me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DIAZ: Yeah, why don't you try?
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess
this is how I see it,
being from New Jersey and all.
Going back and forth from
the island to Jersey,
definitely got mixed messages
about what beauty meant.
My hair, for example--
[INAUDIBLE] but I
couldn't wear it like this
because then I was [SPANISH],,
and I didn't look presentable.
Back in Jersey,
back home, I could
spend a day or two washing it
and leaving it kinky and curly,
and it was OK.
It was all right as long
as I kept it wrapped up.
But in DR, they're very strict,
just to use that as a metaphor
and just as a very symbolic
view of how women are perceived.
In DR, if I were to leave the
house and not straighten it,
that would look
bad on the family.
So it was just a
different way of--
AUDIENCE: Straighten your
hair, like as in no curls?
DIAZ: Mm-hmm.
There was another hand.
Does somebody else
want to try that one?
No?
AUDIENCE: They're
all passing, man.
DIAZ: Yeah.
I mean, I think
Santo Domingo isn't
very different from some
of the communities we
have in the United States.
Negrophobia is just
absolutely rampant,
and I think that people
don't like to talk about it.
But I mean, the
level of self-hatred
that I encounter
in Santo Domingo
has a perfect analog
in the United States,
has a perfect analog.
So when I hear a lot of people
trying to other the Caribbean
and say, things are
worse in the Caribbean,
I'm always like,
worse than what?
What the fuck are
you talking about?
It's such a weird question
because it's like,
worse than what?
What's your standard?
And so I know that when--
it was intense because when
we were in Santo Domingo,
there was like--
I mean, in my community where
I grew up, I grew up in a--
I mean, my name was a
testament to that I grew up
in a Dominican and
Haitian community,
and I was probably the
lightest skinned person
they'd seen in 500 years.
They were so excited
they produced me.
Everybody was just like, my
goodness, we worked so hard.
And it was very clear.
It was so very clear.
It was just so very clear
on the island, the things
that were attributed to us.
It didn't matter how
fucked up ugly I was.
People were like, oh,
[? tan ?] [? cute. ?] I'm like,
you're bugging.
But then we came to
the United States,
and we noticed
something even worse
is that the United States--
the United States, I guess,
their racial measurements
are at the millimeter
wave so that,
for example, my older
brother is lighter than me.
And when we went to school,
people used to throw shit at me
and boo me, and my
brother would come in.
They'd be like, oh,
he's got straight hair
and no signs of negritude.
So I wasn't sure what
the difference was.
Well, I mean, I kind of
got lucky because, I mean,
I grew up with a lot of sisters,
like women in my family,
and they were real
good at bashing it out
of us in our heads.
So by the time I got to writing,
I had already, quote unquote,
"resolved these issues,"
most of them in my head.
And so what I tend to do in my
work is just torture people who
haven't.
Oh no, it's a whole
crew of evil Dominicans,
people who I absolutely adore.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: [? I ?] [? see a ?]
[INAUDIBLE] between your work
and that of Piri Thomas in
Down These Mean Streets.
And it's like that whole urban
Latino American experience.
Did you have any influences
from Latino American authors,
and if so, who?
DIAZ: Yeah, I
mean, well, for me,
I mean, Piri Thomas's Down
These Mean Streets is like--
it's one of those
founding texts, right?
And it was definitely one of the
earliest Caribbean Latino texts
to like do some good things
like talk about race,
et cetera, et cetera.
But there was also some really
like wild, fucked-up shit,
like unreconstructed--
like just unquestioning
misogyny and just wildness.
And so it was a real
important text for me to read,
but I was much more affected
by a lot of the women writers
like, Cristina García and Sandra
Cisneros and people who were
about 50 times--
I was telling another class
[INAUDIBLE] us writers always
pick--
well, some of us pick
better parents than we are.
And so for me, it was like, Toni
Morrison was a huge influence.
A brother from DC
called Edward P. Jones,
remarkable short story writer,
probably one of the most
underrated short-story
writers in the country--
and he wrote a
short-story book called
Lost in the City, which
the entire book was
set in Washington, DC.
And it was just remarkable where
he organized this collection
around DC
geographically, and that
was just so dope because most of
the kids I knew from New Jersey
didn't want to use New
Jersey as background
for anything because New
York has a way of erasing.
Everybody I know
from New Jersey--
they live one week
in New Jersey.
They're like, yeah,
I'm from the Bronx.
I'm like, oh, nigga, please.
What are you talking about?
I saw you at
Spotswood, you clown.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: If you want to get
to some of the political issues
in New York and New Jersey,
they just had [INAUDIBLE] about
profiling, stopping black and
Latino cars on the turnpike,
and [? they ?] [? fired ?]
[? somebody. ?] Do these kind
of things come up in your
writing or affect your writing
or feel like talking
about some of those?
DIAZ: I mean, I was actually
interested in asking like--
we were talking earlier
in another class
about the Mumia Abu-Jamal case.
Are people organized on
this campus for that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: Huh?
AUDIENCE: I haven't heard much.
I did it in high school
in social justice,
but I haven't heard
[INAUDIBLE] here.
Just recently,
[INAUDIBLE] posters up
the next rally in April.
DIAZ: Yeah, see, I'm
disappointed in you guys.
I know you work hard, but we
have the Mumia Abu-Jamal march
on in Philadelphia.
We all know he's on death row.
We all know that he's
an ex-Black Panther,
an important
anti-police-brutality activist
and a member of like--
I don't know,
[? one of our-- ?] I
think just someone who was very
important who was framed for--
thank you.
See, we've got someone
who brought it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but it's here.
DIAZ: I'm glad that's there.
I didn't even see that.
And then the rally is
April 24th in Philadelphia,
and some of you
students should organize
to take some buses down there
so MIT could have a contingency.
And that's my plug
for politics is
to try to get people to organize
because we organized Syracuse
recently.
And we got like four
buses going down there,
and Syracuse students
are about nothing.
I love them to death, but
they ain't about shit.
So if we can get them to go--
AUDIENCE: I brought the sign up.
I'm affiliated with Revolution
Books in Harvard Square.
There are groups
in the city, but it
hasn't gotten [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: MIT needs some buses.
I want to see [INAUDIBLE] when
I'm at the rally smoking up,
I want to see some of you guys.
AUDIENCE: One thing,
people don't read the news
or watch the news.
Like if you cited this
name, "Amadou Diallo,"
how many people in this
audience would know that name?
DIAZ: I think
"Amadou," people know.
Diallo shooting?
AUDIENCE: Ask.
Ask them.
DIAZ: How many people don't
know the Diallo shooting?
Raise your hand.
You're wilding.
What happens here?
Now, if I tell you
who Amadou Diallo is,
he's the cat who
in New York City
was shot 41 times by the police.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
DIAZ: Now you know.
Yeah, that's bad.
AUDIENCE: MIT students
don't know [INAUDIBLE]
for the most part [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: It's a dangerous habit.
Other questions or comments
or beef you want to roll into?
Up front here, then
we'll move back.
AUDIENCE: How do you
[? like ?] teaching?
DIAZ: I mean, I always felt
a certain missionary zeal
about teaching because we used
to gripe all the time about not
having any professors of
color, and so for me, that's
really important to get in
there and work my students
and not just be
in the classroom,
but do organizing work.
And that's cool,
and getting students
prepared for grad school.
I mean, our big thing is to
get our undergrads prepared
for grad school.
When we were grad
students at Cornell,
each year, the grad
students, the Latino
and black grad students
dedicated themselves
to producing 10 grad
students every year.
So we placed 10 students
in grad schools,
and that was just shit
we did on the side.
And I think that's so important
because one of the failings--
I don't want to sound too
much like I drink too much,
but I feel like, if anything,
the failings of some
of the movements that came
out of the '60s and '70s
was some of the weird
ownership issues that came out
where mentorship is a problem.
You tend not to see really good
mentorship from one generation
to the next.
You don't.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see a lot of these
older activists reaching out
to young people to have
these young people train
them to replace them.
What they wanted were followers.
They weren't training
anybody to replace anybody,
and so that's what I think
teaching is really important.
And I find it to
be like-- we need
to place people in grad
school and other things.
There's people who aren't
grad-school orientated.
We need to place them in really
good community jobs and get
people going, and we got
to-- the attrition rate
at universities--
I don't know how the Latino and
black student attrition rate
is here, but when
I was at Cornell,
it was like the
highest in the country.
You know what attrition rate is?
Y'all bugging.
You're supposed to be
the smart students.
Attrition rate is when
students drop out.
So at Cornell, we
had-- the Latino
and black students were
dropping out of Cornell
with an average
grade point of a C,
so that meant they
weren't failing out.
They were cold bolting.
They were just breaking
loose, and so we
were trying to figure
out ways to stop that,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
[INAUDIBLE] some--
[? go ?] [? ahead. ?]
AUDIENCE: [? You ?]
[? may have ?] addressed
[INAUDIBLE] somewhere else, but
I'm curious about your story
"Ysrael."
I'm curious about--
is that a common name?
DIAZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering
why you named your character
Ysrael, and I also
wondered if you
would speak to some of the
American and Dominican tension
in that story.
I was curious about
Yunior, since it
didn't strike me that--
I don't speak Spanish.
I'm sorry, so I don't
know whether Yunior
is a common Spanish nickname
or affectionate name or--
DIAZ: Yeah, half of Santo
Domingo is called Yunior,
and Ysrael is a [INAUDIBLE]--
Ysrael's one of my boys back in
Santo Domingo who drives a cab,
and he was always like, yo,
put me in a fucking story, kid.
I was like, no doubt.
Yeah.
Yeah, so it was cool,
though, because I'd
gone to Santo Domingo for
part of the book tour,
and we had a radio interview.
And if you think this
country has class problems,
Santo Domingo is ruled
by oligarchical elites,
so you can't imagine the
class problems there.
So we were on the radio.
We were wilding
out on the radio,
and all the ex-commies
and left-wing people
were calling up.
And they were just like,
yo, fuck the rich people.
And halfway through
all this stuff,
my friend Ysrael called
me from his cab phone,
and he was like, somebody
ate my face in your story.
So I said, come on, now.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I was
interested in finding out
more about what you did to get
Latino minority students, let's
say, [? interested. ?] Can
you tell me a little bit
more [INAUDIBLE]?
DIAZ: Sure.
The most important thing is to--
I mean, we came to
college-- again,
we were really evil because
we'd been trained at Rutgers,
which is a very active school.
And so we came in, and
we had law students.
And we had accounting students.
We had all sorts of students.
And the first thing we dissolved
was this artificial separation
between grad students
and undergrads,
so we just started
wilding out and go
into the undergrad meetings and
shutting our fucking mouths,
so we would never speak
during the undergrad meetings.
We just let them run things, and
if they needed any of our help,
we would do it.
And then we would start
offering just services.
We would start being
like, yo, if anybody's
interested in grad
school, if anybody
wants to talk about it--
and the first thing is,
you've got to physically
be there for your students.
This old just show up and try to
help them out, that's bullshit.
I mean, so much of what we
do as activists and flows
across interpersonal
relationships,
and that was our
most important thing
was to break down those walls.
And the next thing
we did was we would
start targeting students
that we thought were really
fucking smart and
shunting them off
to classes of our
peers and friends.
So my friend Paula was a
PhD in history or English,
and we would be like, yo,
you got this undergrad kid
running around,
[? and he ?] should
be in one of your classes.
And the same thing--
we would just
[? pamp ?] ourselves out
during our office hours.
All of us would give
our office hours out,
and it would be like
open paper-writing stuff.
You could bring
any papers through,
and we would work
on them for you.
So these kids would be funny
because my other kids would
be waiting to meet
me from a real class,
and these kids
would just break in.
And I'd tell my other students--
I'm like, oh, this is
very important meeting.
And that really
helps, and I know
that sounds kind of stupid.
But I mean, we're
kind of blockheads,
so we weren't trying
to do no master theory.
Our theory was if we
put ourselves out there,
people are going
to respond to that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if you
could share some of your dreams
for the future for
yourself and some of goals
that you had professionally,
I mean, as a writer.
DIAZ: Yeah.
I mean, that's a nice question.
Thank you, but I'm
not so certain.
I'm like, I want to
want to talk about--
I mean, I came from--
some of us here--
my parents and my
grandparents were farmers.
And so farmers are funny because
they don't plan on anything,
and I think part of
that was given to us.
I've never seen anybody
in my family dream
longer than their arm, and
it's not a great thing.
I mean, I actually
don't recommend
it highly because,
I mean, it makes
us very blinkered in some ways.
And I mean, I don't want
to just attribute it
to some family upbringing.
It could've just been
[? something ?] [? on ?]
our side, so I'm really guarded
by that because I'm always
convinced a meteor is going
to hit my car or something.
So I mean, one of the things
I just want to keep doing
is just keep doing
organizational work,
and also, it's important
for any of us who can write
to do all kinds of writing.
So all kinds, no matter
what genre it is,
I think we have to tear it up.
I'm sort of mad at some of
our other writers who are,
quote unquote,
"literary" haven't just
tackled every genre they
can possibly tackle,
which means I think
Toni Morrison needs
to write a horror book
on the real just to mess
up with these boundaries.
If I stick around
long enough, I'd
like to do some of that work.
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of changing genres,
are you planning
on writing a novel?
Do you have anything in mind?
DIAZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Tell us about
some of the characters.
DIAZ: OK.
AUDIENCE: If you can.
DIAZ: Yeah, I'm writing
a novel, and I'm not
going to take the title of
it because I'm absolutely
convinced by telling you
the title of it, that's
when the meteor hits.
But I'll tell you, the first
section is from a film.
Do you know this film,
Exterminating Angel?
Anyway, when I was a kid, my
father was a real film buff
for this [? hick, ?] and he
used to talk about this film,
Exterminating Angel.
And as a kid, you're like,
Exterminating Angel, word up.
You're ready to
see this nonsense.
And then it turns out to be some
Buñuel film where people just
sit around and talk,
so it was not fun.
And so the first section is
called Exterminating Angel,
and what it's about--
it's this insane,
absolutely insane book
about a new minority group.
There's a new minority
group in the United States,
and it's actually based
off of an Octavia Butler
story in Bloodchild, a
really wonderful story where
she imagines people
with this illness who
are discriminated against.
So I just took that one
further and imagined
an entirely new group,
a minority group,
and everybody calls them
mules because they're sterile.
And it's just a
real simple story
about this guy named Lucero.
He's in an underground
railroad, and he just
spends his time smuggling
mules out of the country.
And it's a United States
now, except that none
of the civil rights
legislation ever passed.
Instead, there was in '68--
I was reading these
National Security Agency--
I was a historian, so
I was into this stuff.
And I was reading all this
stuff in the National Security
Agency, and they had
prepared, in '68,
if there had been mass-scale
rioting, that they would
incarcerate 10% to 15% of the
black and Latino population
and put them in
huge prison camps
and declare a
state of emergency.
And so I thought these documents
are really interesting,
finding them, so what
I was going to do
was imagine a United States
where none of the civil rights
legislation was passed.
Instead, a state of
emergency was declared,
and the plan went through.
And this is 50 years later
when the state of emergency
continues to be,
and these characters
are living in this world.
And it's about this guy named
[? Lucho ?] and his beloved
girlfriend, [? Yas, ?] and both
of them are sort of conductors.
And they both hate each
other and are pissed off,
and it's about their life.
And what I'm trying
to do is to take--
I know this sounds
kind of crazy,
but it's kind of
like cut and paste
because what I'm trying
to do is take stuff out
of the common culture, like
when people talk about,
for example, during
the Vietnam War,
experimentations
done on soldiers.
I love that kind of folk
history, and so what I'm doing
is I'm just taking
this folk history
and just pretending
it's all real.
I know this sounds berserk.
Good luck, plenty of good luck.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to get this and then--
AUDIENCE: How much of yourself
do you put in your characters?
Is there one character that
you can think of that really
[? represents ?] [? you? ?]
DIAZ: I, mean I think the
Yunior and the Rafa character
are based on me my brother,
and so the Yunior character
tends to be the main narrator.
But I mean, life is stranger
than fiction, so I mean,
I had to leave a lot of stuff
out and change a lot of things.
So I wouldn't exactly say
Yunior was me, [? ever. ?]
I mean, my mother always
answers that question the best
because when she read
the book in Spanish,
she was always like, I'm a
lot funnier than this woman.
And I'm like, [INAUDIBLE].
Uh-huh, and--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: No, just no.
It's like writing poetry.
It doesn't-- those are really
important forms and I have no
talent or interest in.
Thank you, though.
And then back there, and then
here and then [INAUDIBLE]
[? get ?] [? this? ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, last little
thing I wanted to ask--
we're talking about
analogs [INAUDIBLE]
about physical beauty
and how there's
an analog for that kind of
self-hatred [INAUDIBLE]..
I was wondering, is there
an analog, do you see,
in a literary sense between--
in the '60s, there was a black
aesthetic to write [INAUDIBLE]
[? of ?] [? artists to ?]
[? write. ?] In the Latino
community, there's kind of a
Latino aesthetic that's being
debated or
[? misconceptualized. ?]
DIAZ: You might know better
than me, in a sense, because I
think that--
I mean, I think--
I mean, I don't know.
I guess what troubles
me most about--
I mean, you want to
talk about aesthetic--
I think the debate
that's happening now
amongst the young
writers I know is
that there's a small
group of us who
think it's good to kind
of write unruly stuff
and to be political
in our lives.
And then there's another
huge group of young writers
who-- they just want
to be celebrities.
It's all about
feeding at the trough.
It's like a bunch of pigs
eating at the trough,
and they're like, don't make
too much too much noise.
You'll interrupt the feeding.
And so I feel like
[? at least ?] one of the--
I mean, I think just some old
stuff hasn't been resolved yet.
I mean, I find so many writers.
I go to writers
conferences a lot.
You get invited,
and these writers
who write very interesting,
complicated things--
or you think they're very
interesting and complicated.
And they start
talking, and they say
some wild, dangerous things.
And you find yourself like--
I mean, this writers who--
I was at a conference recently
with a bunch of, quote unquote,
"very famous" established
black writers,
and it was painful to behold
because the entire time, these,
quote unquote, "famous black
writers"-- all they wanted
to talk about was white people.
And I was just like,
you're an idiot.
That conversation is played out.
It's about time for
communities to start
speaking to each other.
I mean, the black
and Latino community
hasn't even begun the
dialogs it needs to have.
I mean, the communities
of color need
to start dialoguing
with each other
in ways that have
never happened before.
Like right now, a lot
of these writers just--
they perform their little
shucking and jiving
under a white gaze,
and I think that that's
really foolish because
every voice should be equal.
And if every voice
is equal, then first,
we need to have a
conversation with each of us.
And every fifth round, we'll
have a conversation with the,
quote unquote,
"white community."
But first, I'd like to see some
other conversations occurring.
Was there a hand there?
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
You [INAUDIBLE] and then--
I'm sure [? I ?] [? dissed ?]
you before, but--
AUDIENCE: I would like
to know how you prepare
yourself [INAUDIBLE] to write.
Do you go to certain
places [INAUDIBLE]??
Is there an emotional
process that you go through?
What do you do?
DIAZ: Yeah, I mean,
preparation is tough.
I think some of you, by
now, have mastered this kind
of like concentration or focus.
You need to.
You wouldn't be here
looking at me right now.
I mean, and part
of it comes with--
I mean, I was telling
an earlier class
is I have to do it first
thing in the morning.
Once I start interacting
with people, it's finished.
Then, I just want to have fun.
I'm a social person.
But the other thing is that--
I know this sounds
corny, but it's
to appreciate the fact that--
I mean, my mother
cleans toilets.
That's her job, and
so I'm like, OK,
she didn't clean toilets so
that I could write some old
[? "bleh blah," ?] some
old fucking nonsense.
And I feel like that, for me,
is something that really helps
me get ready to start writing.
It's like, think
about the old lady,
and then I'm like,
OK, time to get going.
[INAUDIBLE]
Your hand was up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
personal things,
but when you left to
go do your schooling
and get your thing done,
how did you deal with maybe
some guilt that came
across [? from being in ?]
the neighborhood.
I know that I've
encountered leaving
my neighborhood as being
like [? shunning ?] to do
my own thing.
Does that make sense?
DIAZ: Yeah, no, it
does make sense.
But I mean, being
an immigrant, you
get great lessons in
leaving your community,
and it's not always leaving.
I mean, some of us feel no
connections to communities,
and I'm like, cool.
But those are not really
the people I'm talking to,
in a way.
I feel like if you feel a real
connection to a community--
again, the community
I belong to isn't
suffering the sort of
things it's suffering
and that it's being put on it
so that I could go to school
and feel real guilty.
I mean, I know this
sounds grandiose and full
of shit and idealistic, but
I really believe this stuff.
It's kind of berserk.
I'm like a sucker.
I think I'll wake up
one day, but I really
believe this stuff.
I was like, they didn't send
me to be a fucking clown,
and that was a real
serious business for me.
They were just
like, go and do good
and don't come back
with some old silliness.
And that helps, but that
doesn't mean it's not there.
I know the first year when I was
at Cornell, I was a wild drunk.
All I did was drink,
drink, drink, drink,
drink, drink because I
missed home really bad,
and I felt like I don't even
know what the hell I was doing.
And so I don't think
it's real easy.
I think a lot of
us who leave home--
it's good to have friends.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [? I just ?]
[? had a question ?]
because you put yourself in
a very influential position
[INAUDIBLE],, and I think
it's great that you can write
and still manage to
kind of multitask.
You write, and you're also
galvanizing a lot of people
and so on.
And just some of the stuff
that came up before--
how do you manage to watch
the evening news every night
and just keep that energy and
keep that idealism that you
have going?
I mean, what keeps
you fighting, I guess?
Just because there's
so much when you look
around [INAUDIBLE] [? down. ?]
DIAZ: Yeah, but I mean,
what am I really doing?
Nobody's really beating
me with a chain.
I think that's
really tough, and I
don't end up in abuse shelters.
That's really tough.
I mean, and I'm not really
all that influential.
Outside of this
room, ain't nobody
know who the fuck I
am, and most of you
here don't even know
who the fuck I am, so--
I mean, I make photocopies
for Mumia Abu-Jamal things,
and I go to meetings for
anti-police brutality.
That doesn't take much time for
me, so I'm pretty much a grunt.
I'm great at making photocopies.
And so again, you just pick
your small stuff and do them,
and it's not like I'm
all that successful.
I should have had
two books out by now.
If I had dedicated
myself to my writing--
I have people who--
we came up together, and they're
going to be happier people.
Guarantee it because they're
just [? sit ?] at home
and write, and they're
already on book three.
And so that's it.
You feel it.
You feel it when your friends
send [? you your ?] third book,
and you're still out in the
street getting spit on by cops.
You're like, huh, this
doesn't amount to much, so--
AUDIENCE: Since you're
[? looking ?] [? out ?]
for the first couple
years of college,
I guess I'm interested in what
it takes to be [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: You know Toni Morrison's--
I love that influential
essay of hers
where she talks about how--
well, I'm going to get Toni.
But I love Toni, but for
me, it just took somebody--
somebody set it straight
in a really good way.
And again, you have to
be personally ready.
This is not like some
old new-age shit,
but for me, I was just like
argh, drinking and getting
into fights.
I was stupid because I'm
this little nerd kid,
but I had for years and
years and years been a boxer.
So I would be like,
hurr hurr, [CLICK],,
so I was just like an idiot.
And one day somebody
was just like--
some woman I never even knew.
I didn't even know who she was.
Some sister just walked by, and
she's like, look at this idiot.
And I was like,
OK, let's do this.
So I mean, that doesn't
give you much, but for me,
that's all it took.
Nothing like being made fun of.
Why?
Are you having difficulty?
Are you wilding out, bro?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] [? just ?]
[? wondering ?] [INAUDIBLE]
experience.
DIAZ: And then,
[? yeah. ?] We're
about to have last
questions here, guys.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: The conference
that you talked about
and the conferences
that you go to,
I'm curious as to whether
the focus on white people
is more of the writers
that came up either before
or during the Civil Rights
Movement, or [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: They're younger than me.
AUDIENCE: Younger than you?
DIAZ: Yeah, well, a
couple were older than me,
but a bunch of them
were younger than me.
I mean--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
name names [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: The only
reason I don't want
to name names is not
because [INAUDIBLE]..
I'll fuck them niggas
up in a minute.
There's no question about that.
But it's also, you start
getting into this personal
"he said, she said."
It gets away from the
issues, and that's
the way people tend to boil
it down is that I'm not
interested in personalities.
I'm really interested
in some of these issues.
It's just disappointing
because I always
hope that the young writers
are going to be beyond kooky,
but late modern capitalism
has a really good way
of making sure
everybody's identical.
I'm like, oh, you
also like money a lot?
That's great.
You're real fucking original.
I mean, whatever.
OK, I'm going to take one last
question because-- well, I'm
going to take two and
try to answer them
both because before you leave,
I'm just going to read you
a page so you can
leave with words.
I'm going to take your question.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious, given
your interest in history
and activism, [? do ?]
you think about trying
to write for a somewhat younger
audience like high school
kids or younger, even?
DIAZ: Yeah, I mean, I want to,
but my characters right now
are so mean to each other
that it really precludes it.
And it's also some of
the ideas I've been into.
I think, though, when I get
my first real novel done,
I think I'll think
about these other things
because I feel like
that's an important genre.
And when I was a kid, I
mean, the young adult books
really set me off.
I can think of some writers who
really had a big impact on me,
so I'd like to
give a little back.
Thank you.
Why would you ask
that question, anyway?
What were you thinking?
AUDIENCE: Well, I just think--
I have read but very little
bit of you [INAUDIBLE]
and you speak to an audience
that's sitting in front of you,
mostly, most directly.
But all of us have already
been formed, as it were.
The clay is pretty well molded.
You want to challenge
some institutional views,
your rampant capitalism, you
have to [? tag up ?] [? to ?]
[? someone ?] younger age.
That's my view, and I wondered
how you thought about that.
DIAZ: Yeah, it's weird.
It's something I learned
in Santo Domingo.
It's a word that they don't
use too much in the United
States is "simultaneity."
So I'm always like,
fuck the "either" or the
"or" because I
think you're right.
But I think it's
good to do both.
Get the young people.
Get everybody every
age, but thank you.
And I think you're quite right.
OK, I mean, and
that was the last--
back there, those--
AUDIENCE: I just had a question.
DIAZ: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Your second story
left me with some mixed feelings
about interracial relationships,
and I wasn't quite sure
what you were trying to drive
home with that short story.
Maybe I just wasn't
clear about that.
DIAZ: Do you want to
elaborate your mixed feelings?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's that
I'm dating a white boy,
and I'm Hispanic.
And it made me wonder if maybe
I was going through a phase.
DIAZ: God.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DIAZ: Somebody else
want to answer that?
You know what?
It's one of those things where--
Again, I don't want to
get into personal issues.
I'd rather just speak on
some old abstractness that
might connect us in some way.
I mean, again, nobody can tell
anybody who the fuck they can
date.
That's just the bottom line.
I've never had any
issues with that,
and I've never
worried about that.
But I do find that
people pretend
that when we talk about
racism, that racism is
a bunch of just discrete little
units that are not connected,
and I don't see that.
I see it as a continuum,
so the kind of self-- and I
never accuse anybody
of self-hatred
because how would you know?
You can't read minds, no
more than how can they know?
Because they can't read
their subconscious.
When somebody tells me that
they have no self-hate,
I have to start laughing.
I'm like, OK, you have total
access to your subconscious?
I'm like, you need
to read [INAUDIBLE]..
Come on, now.
This book's been
out for 30 years.
But for me, what I find
interesting is some very
simple things we were talking
about in another class
where there's some very simple
patterns about desire and race.
And the fact that
they are constant,
that they're almost
constant, they're
almost like a law
of physics, right?
It was like, we were
joking with another class
before I [INAUDIBLE].
Some of the students are here.
And me my boys when
we were coming up,
we always notice that
no matter who we dated,
they were always
lighter skinned than us.
And then one of my friends
did this hilarious thing
where he took every
single basketball player--
and just watching ball because
he's an obsessive ball--
and he just sat down with a
notebook for an entire season
and discovered that like
every single basketball
player dates somebody
or is married to someone
lighter skinned than them.
And the fact that it occurs with
such perfection and precision
and without any
disruptions of it
really speaks to
some wild-ass shit.
I mean, you couldn't
get that pattern
unless you tried over time.
And I guess that's
the sort of stuff I
try to critique in my stories.
Whether it has some relevance
to you personally, good luck.
But I do think that
there is a lot of that,
and there's a lot of--
what we consider beauty
is some wild shit.
It's culturally
pre-programmed, so I
think it's good to
disrupt some of it.
Whatever.
I mean, I'm just putting an
intellectual spin on something
that my friends in East Harlem
could say in two seconds.
Fuck that.
And you had that
question, and that's that?
AUDIENCE: I had a question also.
It seems like you pride yourself
on being Latino, Hispanic,
black, and I'm not sure--
Caribbean, Dominican.
I was wondering where you think
the line should be drawn with
being celebrating race and
singling someone out for race
because sometimes it seems
like where in America,
we call attention to
your race so much,
sometimes people start seeing
[? others ?] [? before ?]
[? they'll ?] [? see ?] people.
Like for example, with women,
if people see [INAUDIBLE] women
[? write ?] women [? in ?]
[? this, ?] women [? in that ?]
instead of saying, well, this is
writing, and then, we have men.
We have women.
We have blacks, Latinos,
whites, whatever--
I'm wondering where you
think the line should
be drawn between celebrating
something and singling them
out.
DIAZ: Thank you.
I mean, I come from a certain
philosophical bent where--
forgive me, but like
I don't think others
could be singled out anymore
than they already are.
I think gender-blind
stuff and race-blind stuff
is foolish nonsense.
Our brains are hard-wired
to recognize difference.
They just are.
They are, and that's it.
I think for me,
it's not a problem
with recognizing differences.
It's describing all sorts
of negative and pejorative
nonsense to it.
And I think in
the States, people
try to confuse those two.
They're like, oh, we
shouldn't talk about race
because that means that--
I'm like, no.
I don't mind being all
these multiple things.
Just don't put negative
shit on it, and that's that.
Just don't put some old
negative shit on it.
And so those of us who want
to do that kind of work,
I think that that's the
most important thing,
and people feel really
uncomfortable with that.
But I'm like, you know what?
You should go-- you learn to
be humble when you travel,
and no matter what you
say about yourself,
people pick your ass out.
I went to Japan.
It was beyond.
Nothing I could say about--
please don't select out.
See me as a human being.
That wasn't working.
And for me the reality
is always the masses
on some old weird shit.
I mean, whenever I walk
in African communities,
they always crack on me.
They're always like,
yo, what are you, man?
But do you know what I'm saying?
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what are you?
I mean, [INAUDIBLE] do you
check "other" in the census box
when you're filling those out?
DIAZ: Oh, I don't check "other."
AUDIENCE: Then
what do you check?
DIAZ: Well, I always checked
that ugly word "Hispanic"
till they changed it to
Latino, but I mean, again, it's
like you have to do things.
For me, I think most of us
have multiple identities
so that I don't mind
going through my list
of multiple identities.
If you're dumb enough
to ask, then you're
dumb enough to have to listen.
So I tend to be like,
it depends where
the question is coming from.
Where the question's coming
from is almost as important
as the way you answer it.
So people will ask
me what you are,
and if I don't like their
attitude, I'll be like,
what am I?
The fuck are you?
That's the answer back to--
and but the way, I mean, I see
it most clearly is I'm like,
it's like a member of the
Dominican diaspora, which
is a portion of the
larger African diaspora.
I'm an immigrant.
I'm a Latino, and
I come from the--
I'm a man, and I come from
the poor communities, urban.
So you see the list grows,
but I don't mind that.
I think that's OK.
All right, I'm just going to
read you guys just one page.
I'm sorry.
Y'all have to leave.
Go ahead.
You guys can go.
No, I don't want to
put you on the spot.
It's just, I just
wanted to leave you
with just this one
little description
from a story, the last
story that I'd published.
And it's just this little piece
on the Dominican Republic,
and it's just this
guy, this narrator
is just talking
about how much he
loves his country, which is this
sort of nonsense, but anyway.
"Let me confess.
I love Santo Domingo.
I love coming home to the
guys in the blazers trying
to push little cups of
Brugal into my hands.
I love the plane landing,
everybody clapping when
the wheels kiss the runway.
I love the fact that I'm
the only nigga on board
without a Cuban link or a
flapjack of makeup on my face.
I love the redhead
woman on her way
to meet her daughter
she hasn't seen
in 11 years, the gifts
she holds in her laps
like the bones of saints.
[SPANISH] has [SPANISH]
now, the woman whispers.
The last time I saw
her, she could barely
speak in sentences,
and now she's a woman.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
I love the bag my mother's
packed, shit for relatives
and something for Magda, a gift.
You give this to her
no matter what happens.
If this was another
kind of story,
I'd tell you about
the sea what it
looked like, what it looks
like after it's been forced
into the sky through a blowhole,
how when I'm driving in
from the airport and see it
like this, like shredded silver,
I know I'm back for real.
I'd tell you how many poor
motherfuckers there are,
more albinos, more
cross-eyed niggers,
more [SPANISH] than
you'll ever see,
and the [SPEAKING SPANISH].
And I'd tell you about the
traffic, the entire history
of late-20th-century
automobiles swimming
across every flat
stretch of ground,
a cosmology of battered
cars, battered motorcycles,
battered trucks,
and battered buses,
and an equal number
of repair shops,
run by any idiot with a wrench.
And I'd tell you
about the shanties
and our no-running-water
faucets and the sambos
on the billboards and the fact
that my family house comes
equipped with the
ever-reliable latrine,
and I'd tell you
about my [SPANISH]
and his [SPANISH]
hands, how unhappy he is
that I'm not sticking around.
And I'd tell you
about the street
where I was born, Calle XXI,
how it hasn't decided yet
if it wants to be a
slum or not and how
it's been in the state
of indecision for years.
But that would make this
another kind of story,
and I'm having trouble
as it is with this one.
You'll have to take
my word for it.
Santo Domingo is Santo
Domingo, and let's all pretend
we know what goes on there."
Thank you.
Have a good night, you guys.